Some tools are built into the device,
as you saw, but
others work by monitoring your
device during normal use,
these are generally available
through Android Studio.
For example, consider Memory Monitor.
Memory Monitor works by tracking how
much memory is currently allocated, and
can be a great way to see how specific
actions or events can affect your heap.
Here we have Sunshine, and
you can see how several events
claimed additional memory.
These were clicks from the list view
to the detail view and back, and
required memory for
the detail fragments.
And here was a change in the location
setting, which sparked a new sync for
new weather data.
You can also see when garbage
collection events occur,
as the free space increases
when this memory is reclaimed.